are you doing
it's my lovin impression very cool ah
cosplaying is dusty this is what he's
gonna look like when he grows up that
poor actor stranger things for trailer
apparently a short teaser one From
Russia With Love I'm excited to check
this out if you guys did not catch it we
did all of our stranger things reactions
for season three up here on YouTube
reaction highlights included and then at
our patreon we do the watch along sync
up with the timecode speaking of which
that's right we're gonna do this check
us out at our patreon page become a
patron oject today weekly Q&A x' TV show
reaction watch along for many shows such
as stranger things season 3 agents of
shield Gotham haunting of Hill House
season 1 Cobra Kai s2 and then there are
shows where we do watch the longest but
also give you the option with reaction
highlights included if you don't want to
sing up so we do those editors adults
and those shows are supernatural Hunter
hunter one punch man Code Geass Death
Note my hero academia movie included
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood attack
on Todd and starting up Doctor Who and
March and you best believe we will be
covering stranger things season 4 so
become a patron object today let's watch
this already
[Music]
epithets in Russia I bet that's Russia
that's Russia
it's Canada theory some good theorist
that's a dog snowmobile
well there goes that theory that it was
da was that doctor's name
Oh Brenner yeah it could be still this
isn't the same setting this isn't that
like vault jail Oh
oh my god I gotta choke no no one's come
up with this this is the origin story Oh
cowboy cowboys already tells frozen over
here the red car entering add the red
card Ian let's talk about this looks
like they didn't want to save that
reveal of hopper being around for the
actual show debut guess not
still could be the doctor though you're
right about that it could be the doc
this is a different setting altogether
they forgot to say Americans at the end
of season three here I didn't lie to you
your parents chose to be nobodies
hey you could even get a crossover with
the show the Americans cuz they're from
Russia they're you that could be that'd
be neat that would actually work out
pretty well if you asked me first
here's what I'm thinking I've heard the
theories go around this seems plausible
there could be a time travel element
infused in here I could by that age
because of stranger things the 80s and
if you look at like the season three
there's a lot of talk about time and
clocks and then those he's is that
they've been giving have been linked to
that there's even like them going to the
theater and a lot of Back to the Future
references they have the Arnold
reference with that one character
Terminator deals with time-travel so as
much as time travel is a bit of a worn
out trope I still think that would
stranger things it's something that I
actually wouldn't mind seeing
implemented into the series feel like it
could be pretty effective actually
especially if they come up with their
own spin on it I don't know really how
you can spin time-travel in a completely
original way but I feel like stranger
things has developed its own world and
aura enough that yeah I mean it would be
right at home here and with you know
you've got portals and gates and at the
end of the last season he like broke
apart like maybe his molecules drifted
like there's a lot of mumbo-jumbo I
think you can hide under just all that
sci-fi Sheen but what I appreciated most
about this I mean yeah I would have
liked to have had thought for you in the
actual show but they don't actually tell
you how were they to show you that
he's here so there's at least that
mystery to be there and I like the tone
of this I liked you know that it's not
as 80s retro it's not as fun it's very
ominous it's free you can feel the cold
barking dogs in this booming music and
atmosphere it yeah yeah yeah and for
season 4 especially I feel like this is
a cool tone for their teaser to take
yeah that's a neat thing because
stranger things are so you know 80
sci-fi influence as much as I led this
talking about the time-travel stuff it's
cool that they tease the bike the actual
first footage of season four to not be
sci-fi yes it's like there's a sci-fi
umbrella all around it the whole reason
why hopper here is due to some sci-fi
thing yeah I get that but in terms of
what we got here I felt like grounded in
a sort of a dark reality and it's neat
to see hopper here and I would love it
if actually a hopper just decided to be
here he's just an employee who signed up
for this he submitted his application
they saw this as a second chance he was
bored being a sheriff in Hawkinsville
yeah he needed the excitement of
building a rail yeah I also I gotta say
man as much as that joke I'm sure it was
gonna be beaten to death about hoppers
how many David Harper there's so many
H's with the harbour ready for Harbor
Hellboy
Hawkinsville yeah yeah you got a lot of
Ages with this dude in your ear where
he's in Black Widow he can't help but
notice the things of Russia being
correlated here in this season clearly
he's a prisoner he's trapped here in
Russia as an American with a completely
new look but then in the Black Widow
trailers it looks like how hopper has
looked in the first three seasons of
stranger things he's embodying the
Russian character he's playing a
character named Alexei and Alexei was a
character in season 13 speaking of which
this is actually the only thing about
Time Trial that can get a little bit
frustrating at times even though I think
endgame did it magically when they
completely undo a bunch of impactful
deaths hey and I that's the one thing I
would want them to do the time travel I
don't want them to like stable XE I
don't want them to save Sean Astin's
character they've already saved hopper
yeah I don't want them to sit go out and
save Billy you know like just let them
be but it would be cool if they did do a
cha-cha will this take place before all
those incidents
Hawkins and maybe he is trying prevent
something because you do see the
demagogue in at the end of season 3 so
maybe we'll find out that like the
Russian somehow invented the demagogue
in them that first opened up the first
void that you know accesses the upside
down or something what I'm truly hoping
for is a scene where you know hopper
like this is in the past and hopper runs
into like a child Alexei and he's able
to give him one piece of wisdom that
will carry he'll give him like a
strawberry slushy or something like that
old [ __ ] yeah the trope - season 3 it's
gonna be a letter that says open this in
1985 don't read it letter as much as I
would have liked to have this been save
a little bit later at least it's not
like you just show hopper not like we
got a whole bunch of the reveal of
hopper leading with this seems
intentional as opposed to this was an
accident you know what I'm ones getting
funny as I you see a trailer like you
see everyone in Hawkins you're seeing
Joyce you're seeing all the kids and
whatever and then at the end you just
look over their shoulder they do that
bass drop Sam yeah just hopper appear
something like justice for hopper and
Han well the year the age the approach
for stranger things I'm sure they've had
like overarching plans but the vibe at
least I've gotten is that they have a
new season and like what do we want to
do specifically with this season maybe
they had a rough idea there's something
about the way how season three ended how
they've been teasing season four would
that Marie audio of him saying like if
this is Joyce calling me I have some
information not sure if it's good or bad
if I forgot exactly how the audio went
down this weird visual image they had a
few months ago that was dealing with
time in the upside-down world I think
you see like hoppers cabin in the
background something like that it's been
a long time those that's imagery for
some reason the vibe I'm like that and
all the seasons matter and it's
important that you always watch the
prior season there's something about
here that seems like a part one and a
part two to me what terms the Sanjib
stranger thing season three and then
this one I feel like this one is
probably planned out a lot more in
advance cause it also feels like it's
coming a little sooner
if there was a bigger wait period think
about like this - in terms of marketing
usually stranger things leads with the
kids 11 or the or the upside down world
especially when the first official
footage we're getting this sort of
grounded look at just hopper and it's
not revealing how he's alive or why he's
alive you're just telling you that he is
alive and he's in a troubling situation
to say it like because I did have some
teaser that said we're not in Hawkins
anymore so maybe the focus of this
season will be a little bit more here
the kids are taking a road trip to
Russia they're on a foreign exchange
trip yeah it's gonna be farm home yeah
Hopkins far from hey I think this can
all work as long as they really make
hoppers return a part of the story and
not just a thing that gets a one-note
explanation and then we move on you know
yeah I guess one thing I've learned from
watching agents of shield is like if you
take a how are they gonna work with this
kind of thing and make it like an actual
plot element that goes you know through
the DNA of the season like I think that
can work how be neat all right guys well
do you have any theories for stranger
things season four leave your thoughts
down below how do you think hopper is
alive subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification will get
notified whenever we got a YouTube video
well check us on patreon become a patron
I check today and speaking of patreon
Matthew the beer NAT beer
I love this individual love him cuz if
there's anyone at her patreon who
resembles hopper the likeness
physicality not really internal nodes
I'm foot that internally it would be
Matt beer every single time he's
informing me in advance that if he has
to lower his pledge or unpledged for a
little bit of time he does always
eventually come back
so whatever upside-down world he's
hidden for a while he eventually does
return and the thing is though he always
informs me the reason why he has to do
those things is because usually if his
family's having a financial difficulty
he's putting his money his financial
efforts towards helping out the ones he
loves that's a real man right there plus
like a real man he looks great in a
Hawaiian shirt and is good at raising
orphan children probably the family he's
referring to he's like ah you know this
little kid I found has tuberculosis I
gotta fix it for a month or two so maybe
what you should do is just let yourself
go grow the big old
beard and then maybe you can audition
get called in for season 5 be young
hopper and then all your family will be
taken care of that you can pledge stay
here all you got is everything and
hopper loves to drink beer like Matt
beer see meant to be